GUNTHER ROLAND: So at the
beginning of each semester,
I ask the students, what have
you heard about Junior Lab.
And what I find is
that some of them
have been worried about having
to take the class since they
joined MIT as freshmen
even before they declared
their majors.
And characterization that
I've heard multiple times
is that junior lab
is a black hole that
swallows up all available time.
And this reputation
was not I would
say completely undeserved.
It is a very challenging class
and it is very time intensive,
and you really have to
be very judicious in how
you invest your effort.
On the other hand,
many of the elements
that we have introduced
in the last few years,
like the flipping the
classroom, like rearranging
a lot of the
curriculum, really were
meant to address this
worry, and to really
preserve and maybe even purify
the essence of the class
while removing some of the
elements that really caused
a lot of students stress.
And I think the best way
to see what we've done
is to really come and try
for yourself and I think join
many students who've found it
in the end a time consuming
but extremely
rewarding experience.